poland says it fears tensions at its
border with belarus will escalate in the
coming days and that this could be the
start of a conflict of an armed nature
on monday polish troop prevented
thousands of migrants from illegally
crossing the frontier three to four
thousand people mainly from the middle
east have masked in the area and are
hoping to get into the eu brussels and
warsaw accused belarus of deliberately
sending the migrants to the area in
retaliation for eu sanctions on the
minsk regime for its human rights
violations
hundreds of men women and children
headed to the belarussian border
they want to enter the european union by
crossing into poland a member state
and many want to travel even further
no go to poland we all go to germany
germany is live no poland
but they were met by barbed wire and
thousands of polish soldiers who have
been stationed along the border
some migrants tried to breach the fence
but were pushed back
poland says the situation is under
control
the eu accuses bella russian president
alexander lukashenko of using the
migrants most who fled war or
poverty-stricken countries in the middle
east to put pressure on the bloc
allowing them to fly into belarus and
then encouraging them to cross into
neighboring eu countries like poland and
lithuania
this is a continuation of the desperate
attempt by the kashankar regime to use
people as pawns to destabilize the
european union
lukashenko's government has denied the
eu's accusations and blames poland for
triggering the escalation at the border
instead of trying to understand the
migrant situation and consulting with
human rights advocates the polish
security forces exerted psychological
pressure by deploying aviation
technology and tear gas
in response to this unjustified use of
force some of the migrants took more
decisive action and began destroying the
polish barriers
poland has declared a state of emergency
in the border region
which includes a media blackout
journalists and humanitarian
organizations are not allowed to get
close to the border
only belarus state media has close
access to migrants and the conditions
they're living in
so many of them doesn't have food water
they have small kids and they're
freezing and the weather is pretty cold
attention attention aid groups support
these reports
at least 10 people have been found dead
on the belarus polish border since the
summer
and dw correspondent guelch paolo cat
joins me for the latest uh poland has
sealed off the kuznitsa official
boarding border crossing what's the
significance of this
well remember kojnitsa is very close to
the place where the quite big group of
migrants came yesterday in the afternoon
so it's the closest one we have there
and what does it mean you know um
it of course means that there can be no
traffic anymore yesterday some traffic
drivers has been asked what's going on
there and they told us it's normal it's
everything normal here so today they
closed it and it of course means that um
yeah that that
it may harm the international trade and
it may also harm mukashenko which some
say has a very vulnerable point on that
and of course a lot of people here in
poland claim poland should close all the
borders should close the border
completely
and
sticking with the polish governments
warned of the possibility of armed
escalation at the border what does that
mean
well there were some reports of blank
shots recently here in poland and also
some reports of men from the belarusian
side who have been seen here on the
polish territory which of course
some reminded of this so-called green
man we had in the ukraine and remember
we have now soldiers on the both sides
on the belarusian side on the polish
site twelve thousand soldiers just on
the polish side so um it's the situation
is explosive now
and the polish prime minister said today
that poland will defend peace in europe
with its partners namely nato and the eu
but so far poland has refused
international help why is that
well it's kind of interesting also for
me that the prime minister and other
government members stressed that uh so
clearly today uh they stressed that it
is a border of the european union and of
a nato member and you know i would not
interpret it as longing for help as we
hear from the beginning of the crisis
that poland is able to manage the crisis
by itself i would rather interpret it
like expressing that poland is securing
europe also which finds poland in a
better position than in the recent times
uh being criticized for the um low
crisis here in the country
all right dw's magdalena gospel cat many
thanks for that